la semaine dernière j'ai lancé une
campagne Ulule pour mon projet de bande
dessinée philorama cette annonce a
suscité votre enthousiasme puisque moins
de 24 heures après le lancement
l'objectif des 100% était déjà atteint
lundi a été franchi le cap des 200 % et
alors où j'enregistre nous en sommes à
plus de 220%. puisque sur l'UL il n'y a
pas de limite on peut dépasser autant
qu'on veut l'objectif l'intérêt étant
que plus la cagnotte grimpe plus vous
recevrez des cadeaux supplémentaires en
plus des contreparties déjà contenues
dans votre pack donc continuez à
soutenir le projet en précommandant la
BD si vous n'avez pas encore eu
l'occasion de le faire objectif
300%. quelques explications pour ceux
qui découvriraient le projet philorama
est une bande dessinée philosophique que
je réalise avec Jules dessinateur
professionnel et David cossenariste et
superviseur technique du projet le
principe de cette bande dessinée c'est
de vous plonger dans la vie quotidienne
de 10 philosophes tout en vous initiant
à leur pensée j'en parle plus en détail
dans la FAQ donc restez connectés vous
en saurez plus dans quelques minutes sur
la page Ulule on a publié un chapitre
entier de la BD le chapitre consacré à
Schopenhauer si vous voulez voir à quoi
va ressembler cette bande dessinée le
mieux est donc de vous rendre
directement sur la page lune je vous
laisse le lien en description et en
commentaire épinglé c'est un projet qui
me tient particulièrement à cœur et je
suis honoré de voir à quel point vous
aussi vous êtes impatient de tenir
filorama entre vos mains merci pour
votre soutien et pour votre enthousiasme
et rendez-vous sur la page Ulule pour la
suite des aventures
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
FAQ 600000 abonnés même si ça fait déjà
plusieurs semaines qu'on a franchi le
cap des 600 000 abonnés mais j'ai été
pas mal occupé ces dernières semaines et
donc je n'ai pas pu faire le montage
plutôt et d'ailleurs je vais commencer
par vous expliquer un petit peu ce qui
m'a occupé parce que comme vous l'avez
vu sur ma chaîne la semaine dernière
j'ai lancé un projet dont j'aimerais
vous parler ce projet vous l'avez vu
c'est l'écriture d'une bande dessinée
alors je ne suis pas seul sur ce projet
je travaille avec un dessinateur qui
s'appelle Jules Jules btrx donc cette
bande dessinée va s'appeler filorama
sous-titré les petites histoires des
grands philosophes et le concept de
cette bande dessinée c'est de prendre 10
grands philosophes et de les mettre en
scène dans des scénarios dans des
scénarios comiques épiques ou tragiques
des scénarios qui correspondent
d'ailleurs à des anecdotes réelles à des
histoires que ces philosophes ont
vraiment vécu et l'idée c'est donc à la
fois de vous divertir puisqu'une bande
dessinée ça reste une oeuvre ludique
mais c'est aussi de vous apprendre des
choses sur le plan philosophique et donc
on a fait en sorte d'incorporer la
pensée des philosophes dans chacun des
scénarios dans chacune des petites
histoires donc vous verrez Jean-Paul
Sartre qui a pris trop de mesquine et
qui croit être poursuivi par des homards
géants vous allez voir Socrate en pleine
scène de ménage avec sa femme le jour de
son procès et pour chaque personnage
pour chacun des 10 philosophes il y aura
une partie histoire et une partie courte
c'est une manière de reprendre l'adage
des classiques qui disait divertir oui
mais à condition d'instruire et donc
dans le cadre de ce projet de bande
dessinée j'ai créé une page Ulule
Ulule c'est le site de financement
participatif donc je vous ai mis le lien
vers la page Ulule dans la description
et en commentaire épinglé et donc sur la
page Ulule vous allez pouvoir
précommander la bande dessinée puisque
la bande dessinée n'est pas encore
terminée elle est encore en cours de la
création et vous allez voir que selon le
montant de votre contribution vous allez
pouvoir débloquer certaines
contreparties parmi les contreparties
vous avez la possibilité de recevoir la
bande dessinée dédicacée vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir votre propre
personnage dans la bande dessinée on a
aussi prévu certains cadeaux beaucoup
plus personnalisés comme par exemple le
portrait sur toile de votre philosophe
préféré donc je vais pas vous faire
toute la liste des contreparties
possibles le mieux c'est que vous allez
voir directement sur la page Ulule et ce
qui est très important c'est de ne
surtout pas trop attendre si vous êtes
intéressé par la bande dessinée parce
que la campagne ne va durer que huit
semaines au total et que passer ces huit
semaines vous n'aurez plus accès à
toutes ces contreparties donc le plus
simple c'est de mettre cette FAQ en
pause d'aller directement sur la page
Ulule et si vous êtes intéressé par la
BD de la commander directement si vous
regardez cette FAQ c'est qu'a priori
vous me suivez vous me suivez peut-être
depuis longtemps et vous savez que je
suis quelqu'un de très exigeant
vis-à-vis de moi-même et vis-à-vis de
mon travail et je peux vous assurer que
ce projet de bande dessinée me tient
particulièrement à coeur et que j'ai
vraiment l'intention de vous livrer un
bel objet parce que c'est vraiment pas
mon genre de lancer des projets et des
appels à contribution sans être
absolument certain de vous livrer
quelque chose de qualité voilà c'était
la grosse annonce que j'avais à vous
faire avant de commencer à répondre à
vos questions je vous rappelle que pour
m'envoyer vos questions pour les FAQ le
mieux c'est de me rejoindre directement
sur mon compte Instagram alors je sais
que beaucoup de personnes sont
réticentes à s'inscrire sur Instagram
pour des raisons que je respecte
totalement mais sachez simplement que si
vous avez déjà un compte facebook
Facebook Instagram c'est le même groupe
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que c'est
sur Instagram que je publie le plus
d'informations c'est le réseau social
sur lequel je suis le plus actif c'est
là où je vous annonce le thème des
prochains épisodes c'est là où je vous
montre des coulisses de la création de
mes épisodes mais Instagram c'est aussi
un réseau social que j'utilise pour
publier des textes philos magnifique des
textes de ma plume et comme je sais que
beaucoup de personnes parfois me
demandent d'exprimer mon avis d'exprimer
mes opinions dans mes épisodes et bien
le mieux pour ces personnes c'est de me
rejoindre directement sur Instagram
parce que c'est là que j'exprime
beaucoup plus mes opinions mes
conceptions ma manière de voir les
choses ce que je fais également dans les
FAQ mais sauf que les FAQ c'est tous les
100000 abonnés alors que sur mon compte
Instagram je publie de manière beaucoup
plus fréquente voilà j'en ai terminé
pour les annonces promotionnelles on va
maintenant pouvoir passer aux réponses à
vos questions c'est parti première
question bonjour Charles peut-on
apprendre la philo avec vous en partant
de zéro alors non seulement on peut
apprendre la philo avec moi en partant
de zéro mais surtout on ne part jamais
de zéro je sais que c'est une expression
qu'on emploie partir de zéro mais en
fait le principe de mes épisodes c'est
justement de m'adresser à des personnes
qui n'ont pas de bagages en philosophie
qui n'ont pas fait d'études de
philosophie qui n'en ont peut-être qu'un
très lointain souvenir remontant à la
terminale mais le fait est que si vous
vous exprimez correctement en français
et que vous avez un niveau de
vocabulaire disons correct vous allez
pouvoir comprendre quasiment tout ce que
je dis dans mes épisodes snap absolument
pas réservé à un public d’universitaire
ou un public de spécialiste je m'exprime
dans mes épisodes comme je m'exprimerai
devant toute personne que je
rencontrerai pour la première fois dans
un bar donc pour répondre à la question
oui on peut apprendre la philosophie
avec mes épisodes en partant de zéro
étant entendu qu'on ne part jamais de
zéro et qu'il suffit d'être curieux pour
pouvoir entrer dans la philosophie
question suivante comment vois-tu la
chaîne le précepteur dans 2,5 10 ans
alors ça c'est une question difficile
évidemment parce que personne lit dans
l'avenir et je ne peux pas dire quel
sera la longévité de mon activité sur ma
chaîne en revanche ce qui est certain
c'est que j'ai encore de très nombre le
sujet à aborder sur ma chaîne et si je
me fie simplement à la longue liste de
thèmes qui est accroché sur mon
réfrigérateur je peux vous dire que j'ai
de quoi tenir encore au minimum 4 ou 5
ans par contre comme tout activité un
temps soit peu lié à la création il y a
toujours ce paramètre de l'inspiration
et de la motivation liée à l'inspiration
qui fait qu'on ne peut pas travailler de
manière mécanique du temps où j'étais
salarié manutentionnaire je ne me posais
pas de questions mon réveil sonner
j'allais travailler j'avais toujours
quelque chose à faire mais quand vous
êtes un créateur et a fortiorer un
créateur à votre compte vous n'avez
personne qui vous dit quoi faire vous
êtes votre propre maître ce qui vous
donne énormément de liberté mais ce qui
vous oblige également à une forme
d'autodiscipline et à prendre l'habitude
de travailler de manière un peu
mécanique or la création c'est le
contraire d'une activité mécanique et
parfois il arrive qu'on ne trouve rien
d'intéressant refroidir ou parfois il
arrive qu'on est l'esprit préoccupé par
d'autres choses ce qui fait qu'à ce
moment là notre outil de travail qui est
notre esprit n'est pas disponible pour
pouvoir produire quelque chose
d'intéressant alors je ne fais pas
partie de ceux qui pensent que la
création repose entièrement sur
l'inspiration je pense que la création
s'est avant tout du travail c'est à dire
de se lever le matin et de se mettre
derrière son bureau parce que souvent on
croit qu'il faut attendre que
l'inspiration arrive pour commencer à
créer la réalité c'est qu'il faut
d'abord commencer à créer pour que
l'inspiration arrive c'est un peu comme
quand on veut reprendre le sport après
une longue période d'inactivité et qu'on
pense que la motivation va s'emparer de
nous et nous faire nous lever notre
canapé en fait c'est le contraire il
faut d'abord se lever de son canapé il
faut faire une première séance qui va
être difficile une deuxième séance qui
va être un peu moins difficile et au
bout de la troisième séance la
motivation sera là de manière spontanée
il y a une sorte de lieu commun il y a
une sorte d'Opin toutes faites qui
circulent sur la création qui consiste à
dire que tout n'est qu'inspiration non
l'inspiration ça se cultive
l'inspiration ça se cherche ça se
provoque et ça se provoque en se mettant
au travail mais il faut quand même
admettre qu'il y a des métiers beaucoup
plus pénibles et quand on a la chance de
pouvoir vivre de la création la moindre
des choses c'est de ne pas trop s'en
plaindre question suivante je découvre
votre chaîne Youtube par quelle vidéo
dois-je commencer puis donc à l'ordre
alors je dirais que le plus simple c'est
tout simplement d'écouter les épisodes
dans l'ordre parce que généralement je
considère comme acquis tout ce que j'ai
dit dans les épisodes précédents et ça
m'arrive assez régulièrement de faire
référence ou de faire des renvois à ce
que j'ai pu dire dans des anciens
épisodes et aussi parce que comme je
tiens à ne pas trop me répéter d'un
épisode à l'autre j'ai tendance à faire
des épisodes de plus en plus approfondi
et donc pour comprendre les épisodes
il est parfois nécessaire d'avoir écouté
les épisodes plus anciens et donc si par
exemple vous regardez un épisode sur le
stoïcisme sur ma chaîne il est
préférable de commencer par le premier
épisode sur le stoïcisme dans lequel je
déblayais le terrain alors que dans les
derniers épisodes sur le stoïcisme je
rentre un peu plus dans le détail même
chose pour Spinoza même chose pour
Platon même chose pour Descartes pour
tous les auteurs dont j'ai parlé
plusieurs fois sur ma chaîne il me
paraît indispensable d'écouter les
épisodes dans l'ordre
question suivante est-ce qu'enfant tu te
posais déjà des questions philosophiques
existentielles oui et ça j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire je crois dans une
précédente FAQ aussi loin que remonte
mes souvenirs je me suis toujours posé
des questions sur le monde je me suis
toujours interrogée j'ai toujours été
curieux et je me souviens même maître
poser la question de Dieu alors que
j'étais à la maternelle que j'avais
environ 4 ans question suivante
quelles activités fais-tu en dehors des
vidéos et de la philo alors
saint-maxence tu le sauras et tu seras
sans doute surpris de la réponse en
t'abonnant à mon compte Instagram salut
as-tu déjà été découragé par la
philosophie au point de vouloir tout
arrêter alors non je n'ai jamais été
découragé au point de vouloir tout
arrêter par contre il est vrai que
parfois on peut ressentir une forme de
lassitude on peut ressentir une forme
d'usure de fatigue psychologique liée au
fait qu'on a l'impression de faire de la
philosophie de manière industrielle je
suis quelqu'un qui aime rentrer dans la
pensée de manière approfondie et ça ça
nécessite du temps et quand on a un
rythme de publication à Honoré on ne
peut pas se permettre de passer de moi
ou trois mois sur un auteur donc
automatiquement on va avoir tendance à
privilégier les auteurs les concepts
courant de penser qu'on connaît déjà
qu'on maîtrise le mieux et donc parfois
c'est un peu frustrant parce que on
aimerait avoir le temps de découvrir de
nouveaux auteurs
d'étudier de nouveaux courants de pensée
et c'est pas toujours possible parce
qu'on a des contraintes parce qu'on peut
pas s'extraire de ces contraintes donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a parfois
non pas découragé au point de vouloir
tout arrêter mais qui m'a parfois
fait remettre en question le sens de mon
travail et la manière dont je voulais
vivre de ma passion donc le jour où
j'aurai plusieurs mois d'avance sur ma
programmation le jour où j'aurai 4 5 6
épisodes d'avance déjà produit bien à ce
moment là je me vois bien moque croyais
un mois pendant lequel je vais me
plonger dans la découverte d'un nouvel
auteur et j'en profiterai évidemment au
passage pour vous préparer un petit
épisode sur l'auteur en question
question suivante
comment être spirituel en étant connecté
au monde la sagesse rend elle heureuse
ma position sur la spiritualité c'est
que plus on se prétend spirituel plus on
est dans une posture spirituelle et plus
on est dans l'acceptation du monde
matériel tel qu'il est et plus on est
authentiquement spirituel ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que parfois on brandit
la carte de la spiritualité pour
justifier le fait d'être inadapté au
monde ou pour justifier le fait de
pouvoir dire tout le mal qu'on pense du
monde je trouve que ce n'est pas être
spirituel que de critiquer le
matérialisme que de critiquer la
superficialité que de critiquer l'ego
pourquoi parce que le matérialisme la
superficialité et l'ego font partie du
monde et que si être spirituel c'est
avoir compris le monde avoir compris le
sens de l'existence
et bien la spiritualité est donc censé
conduire à la compréhension de ces
choses qu'on dénonce je ne vois pas ce
qu'il y a de spirituel dans le fait de
pointer l'ego des autres je ne vois pas
ce qu'il y a de spirituel dans le fait
de dire que le monde est corrompu et que
donc il faut le rejeter je ne dis pas
qu'il faut accepter la corruption ou
qu'il faut trouver ça normal je dis
simplement que ce n'est pas ça la
spiritualité alors nul n'est tenu à la
spiritualité qu'on soit bien d'accord
mais je considère que la spiritualité
c'est la démarche qui consiste à se
réconcilier avec la matière et que
lorsqu'on se réconcilie avec la matière
on ne parle plus de spiritualité
précisément parce qu'on l'a intégré et
qu'on n'a pas besoin de parler de
quelque chose qu'on a intégré en fait si
vous voulez moi j'ai entendu beaucoup
trop de personnes
vanter leur spiritualité
intellectualiser leur spiritualité au
point que j'avais l'impression au bout
d'un moment que pour ces personnes la
spiritualité devenait un moyen de se
distinguer de la masse à un moyen de se
placer au dessus des autres et je
trouvais ça totalement contradictoire
avec la démarche spirituelle moi je ne
me considère pas particulièrement comme
quelqu'un de spirituel mais je ne me
sens pas non plus l'obligation de
dénoncer l'ego de mon voisin ou de lui
dire qu'elle se trompe quand elle réagit
de tel ou telle manière à ce qui lui
arrive parce que pour moi être spirituel
ce n'est pas être un donneur de leçon
être spirituel ça ne consiste pas à dire
je suis spirituel et vous ne l'êtes pas
et parfois le meilleur moyen d'être
réellement spirituel c'est de ne plus
chercher à l'être moi je trouve beaucoup
plus spirituel le fait de faire de
l'humour subtil le fait de faire des
jeux de mots poétiques que le fait de
donner des leçons spiritualité et donc
quand je lis la question comment être
spirituelle en étant connecté au monde
bien en fait j'ai l'impression que tu
donnes la réponse comment être spirituel
en étant connecté au monde être connecté
au monde c'est sentir le monde sans le
juger et si la spiritualité a un
adversaire c'est-à-dire quelque chose à
abattre c'est le jugement et quand je
parle du jugement je ne parle pas du
jugement intellectuel je ne parle pas du
jugement entre le vrai et le faux je
parle du jugement qui fait qu'on se
place très souvent dans la position de
l'inquisiteur dans la position de celui
qui sait ce qui est bien et ce qui est
mal et qui veut convaincre les autres
pour ne pas dire les convertir à sa
propre conception du bien quand on est
un tant soit peu spirituel il y a une
chose qu'on a intégré c'est le fait que
chacun avait besoin de vivre ses propres
expériences pour comprendre les choses
selon son propre chemin d'évolution
parce qu'il y a des choses qui ne se
comprennent pas par des discours qui ne
se comprennent pas par les livres mais
qui se compr parce qu'on les a vécus et
parce qu'on les a vécus dans telle
circonstances à telle époque dans tel
contexte et souvent on se croit habilité
à donner des leçons de vie aux autres
parce que nos expériences nous auront
fait comprendre certaines choses et
qu'on pense qu'il suffit de plaquer sur
l'autre l'enseignement qu'on a retenu de
notre expérience pour qu'il le
comprennent et pour qu'ils se mettent
aussitôt à l'appliquer mais ça ne marche
pas comme ça je crois beaucoup plus dans
les vertus de l'écoute c'est à dire du
fait d'entendre ce que l'autre a à nous
dire sans le juger sans considérer que
parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord il a tort
et nous avons raison être capable
simplement de regarder la personne qui
nous parle d'entendre ce qu'elle nous
dit sans chercher absolument à réagir ne
pas considérer qu’écouter c'est
simplement patienter en attendant de
pouvoir répondre mais simplement
regardez la personne et l'écouter
jusqu'à être connecté à sa conscience
parce que c'est très difficile d'être
connecté à la conscience de l'autre les
limites de notre univers sont les
limites de notre conscience et parce que
comme notre conscience est la seule
conscience à laquelle nous ayons un
accès direct on pense spontanément qu'on
peut entrer dans la conscience de
l'autre sans avoir à l'entendre donc on
devient spirituel en se connectant au
monde et se connecter au monde ça passe
par l'observer l'écouter l'entendre sans
le juger question suivante
les livres qui ont changé ta vision du
monde il y a un livre philosophique qui
a considérablement changé ma vision du
monde c'est l'Éthique de Spinoza et
quand je dis qu'il a changé ma vision du
monde à vrai dire c'est inexact parce
que c'est un livre qui lorsque je l'ai
lu m'a plutôt conforté dans la vision
que j'avais du monde mais sans avoir
réussi jusqu'à lors à poser des mots
dessus et ça c'est quelque chose que je
trouve intéressant quand notre évolution
se fait par la reconnaissance de quelque
chose qu'on savait déjà j'ai un côté
assez platonicien et je suis assez
sensible à sa doctrine de la
réminiscence c'est-à-dire à l'idée que
connaître ses reconnaître connaître
c'est prendre conscience de ce qu'on
savait déjà et donc quand j'ai lu
l'Éthique de Spinoza ou plutôt quand je
l'ai étudié à l'université parce que si
je l'avais lu tout seul dans mon coin je
sais pas si j'aurais réussi à comprendre
quoi que ce soit mais quand j'ai étudié
les tics de Spinoza j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'on m'offrait un système
de compréhension du monde qui a
complètement bouleversé ma vision des
choses question suivante
quels conseils pouvez-vous donner aux
étudiants en philosophie lettres
un conseil très pragmatique qui est de
savoir quel est votre projet
professionnel on se lance parfois même
souvent dans des études littéraires ou
artistiques simplement par plaisir par
passion par intérêt et on en oublie un
peu trop vite la question du débouché
professionnel je pense qu'il n'y a rien
de honteux qu'il n'y a rien de dégradant
à faire des études littéraires en se
posant la question de ce qu'on va en
faire donc si vous faites des études
longues un master voire un doctorat ce
que je peux vous conseiller c'est de
vous poser déjà la question
quel sera votre domaine ou votre auteur
de spécialité parce que ça paraît tout
bête mais lorsqu'on fait de longues
études littéraires en termes de
débouchés professionnels à part
l'enseignement il y a pas grand chose et
donc quitte à devenir enseignant autant
devenir enseignant dans la branche qui
nous intéresse et donc pour ça avoir une
spécialité et on s'improvise pas
spécialiste ou d'une période c'est un
travail de fond c'est un travail qui se
mène sur plusieurs années donc ce que je
peux vous conseiller c'est le plus tôt
possible déterminer le sujet qui vous
intéresse le plus et qui deviendra votre
sujet de spécialité question suivante
si personne ne sait quel est le but de
la vie alors pourquoi les philosophes
disent dit tenir bien je suis pas
totalement d'accord avec la formulation
de cette question puisque tous les
auteurs ne disent pas de tenir à la vie
je prendrai par exemple shopenhauer qui
explique bien que l'existence est
absurde que l'existence n'est synonyme
que de souffrance et d'ennuis et donc
shopenhauer ne fait pas partie des
philosophes qui disent qu'il faut tenir
à la vie si on prend le cas d'Albert
Camus Albert Camus explique dans le
mythe de Sisyphe que la seule question
philosophique vraiment sérieuse c'est
celle du suicide ce qui veut dire que la
valeur de la vie et tout sauf une
évidence et je ne parle même pas d'un
auteur comme sioran vous allez voir
qu'en termes de pessimisme sur la vie on
est quand même sur un sacré niveau donc
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait uneanimité
des philosophes quant à la valeur de la
vie en revanche je pense que chaque
philosophe va avoir propre
interprétation de ce qui donne du sens à
la vie et la valeur de la vie qui va en
découler dépend de cette interprétation
question suivante comment la philosophie
aborde le sujet spiritualité question de
Juliana alias IAM jujubafitte que je
vous invite à les suivre sur Instagram
alors je dirais que toute philosophie ne
contient pas des éléments de
spiritualité en revanche il existe une
approche philosophique de la
spiritualité je prendrai comme exemple
la question de la mort chez Socrate et
donc chez Platon à travers la notion de
migration des âmes Socrate pensée et il
n'était pas le seul à son époque c'était
une croyance répandue une croyance qui
d'ailleurs vient des Égyptiens
que l'âme se détachait du corps au
moment de la mort que l'âme était
immortelle et qu'après la mort l'âme
allait rejoindre le séjour des essences
éternelles pour Socrate l'existence
physique
l'incarnation n'est qu'un passage n'est
qu'un moment qui n'est pas le tout de la
vie
parce que pour Socrate la vie ne se
traduit pas forcément par l'existence
matérielle la vie avec un V majuscule
c'est la vie dans le monde des essences
ce que les religieux appelleraient
l'au-delà parce que dans cette
conception
les vivants proviennent des morts alors
évidemment dit comme ça ça nous paraît
très étrange très déconcertant mais
quand on arrive à se placer dans cette
mentalité dans cette manière de
percevoir les choses ça fait sens alors
nous aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde
matérialiste matérialiste au sens
philosophique c'est-à-dire qui considère
que rien n'existe en dehors de la
matière et partant de ce point de vue la
vie et la conscience ne sont que des
émanations de la matière en gros la
conception moderne c'est celle qui
consiste à dire que l'esprit est une
conséquence de la matière et non pas
l'inverse la conception de Socrate la
conception des anciens en général c'est
l'inverse l'idée des anciens c'est que
l'esprit préexiste à la matière que
l'esprit préside à la matière et ça ça
ne relève pas simplement d'une croyance
au sens religieux du terme c'est une
conception philosophique c'est une
conception métaphysique qui considère
que l'esprit ne peut pas être limité
dans le temps et dans l'espace et que si
on se pose la question du commencement
si on se pose la question de l'origine
il nous sera impossible de placer cette
origine dans la matière étant entendu
que la matière elle est limitée dans le
temps et dans l'espace le monde matériel
est régi par une loi qui est la loi de
la causalité
la loi de la causalité implique la
temporalité à savoir qu'une cause ne
peut pas être postérieure à son effet la
cause est toujours antérieure elle
précède toujours l'effet donc la loi de
la causalité implique la temporalité et
la temporalité implique le commencement
donc c'est là qu'on peut parler d'une
approche philosophique de la
spiritualité parce qu'on touche à des
notions spirituelles mais sur la base
d'un raisonnement rationnel donc je
dirais que la philosophie aborde la
spiritualité en essayant de créer un
terrain rationnel à la réflexion
spirituelle question suivante
comment les religions ont pu tenir des
milliers d'années je dirais que les
religions ont pu tenir des milliers
d'années et continueront sans doute à
tenir des milliers d'années parce que
les religions viennent répondre à un
besoin humain qui est le besoin de sens
je trouve qu'il y a une tendance moderne
un peu facile à regarder la religion de
haut
et à considérer que nous aurions dépassé
le stade de la religion je pense que
c'est une erreur et je pense que c'est
une erreur qui nous rend aveugle aux
formes contemporaines de la religiosité
pour nous la religion c'est croire dans
des dieux c'est à dire dans des entités
fictives dont nous n'avons pas la
moindre preuve mais on oublie que la
religion ne se résume pas à ça ne se
réduit pas à ça
qu'il y a dans la religion une double
dimension à la fois
transcendante c'est à dire verticale de
liens de l'individu à une divinité mais
aussi un aspect horizontal qui est
l'aspect de la communauté religieuse
donc une religion est un ensemble de
croyances qui unifie un groupe et donc
si on retire une religion d'un groupe
social on retire le ciment de l'union
entre les membres du groupe alors oui on
va dire
croire dans des dieux à tête d'animaux
c'est totalement stupide c'est
totalement absurde oui mais sauf que
aujourd'hui nous avons des croyances qui
paraîtront tout aussi stupide et tout
aussi absurde à ceux qui vont nous
suivre alors évidemment par définition
on ne peut pas dire quelles sont les
croyances que nous avons actuellement
qui vont être jugés stupides par la
postérité tout simplement parce que nous
ne savons pas qu'il ne s'agit que de
croyances mais l'histoire est faite de
mille exemples qui prouvent que ce qu'on
croit à un moment donné dans l'histoire
et voué à être renversé et aujourd'hui
le simple fait qu'il y ait autant de
querelles scientifiques sur la question
de la matière sur la question de la
nature et du fonctionnement de la
matière ça devrait nous alerter sur le
fait qu'il est fort probable que les
croyances que nous avons encore
actuellement sur la nature de la matière
se révèle totalement fausse dans
quelques décennies les expériences qui
ont été menées en physique quantique et
je pense à la plus célèbre de ces
expériences qui est l'expérience des
fentes du Young cette seule expérience
prouve à quel point on ne comprend pas
le fonctionnement réel de la matière et
en l'absence d'une compréhension
complète et véritable du fonctionnement
de la matière on est obligé de
fonctionner sur des croyances je disais
tout à l'heure que la matière régie par
la loi de la causalité mais même ça ça
pourrait être qualifié de croyance dans
la mesure où on a pu déterminer le fait
que une cause et un effet pouvait être
simultanée et si une cause et un effet
peuvent être simultanées ça prouve non
seulement qu'on a peut-être pas compris
ce qui était la matière mais qu'on a
peut-être pas non plus compris ce qui
était le temps nous avons une croyance
selon laquelle le temps est quelque
chose qui s'écoule et qui s'écoule de
manière uniforme mais ça c'est notre
perception du temps c'est notre
conception humaine du temps il est tout
à fait envisageable que la recherche
nous permet un jour de comprendre la
nature véritable du temps et à ce
moment-là on s'apercevra que notre
conception du temps était une croyance
une croyance qui paraîtra tout aussi
stupide et absurde que nous apparaît la
croyance dans des dieux à tête d'animaux
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que derrière la question de savoir
comment les religions ont-elles fait
pour tenir milliers d'années il faut
éviter de projeter l'ombre de
prétentions modernes qui consiste à
croire que nous avons résolu la plupart
des questions en réalité il y a une
constante de l'humanité qui est que
l'humanité repousse constamment les
limites de sa propre ignorance et que
nous sommes tous les ignorants de la
génération qui va nous suivre il me
semble que l'Occident moderne
souffre quand même d'un complexe de
supériorité qui nous fait regarder ceux
qui ont vécu dans le passé comme des
personnes qui sont nées avant
l'intelligence il me semble qu'il
faudrait se méfier de cette tendance
qui nous fait voir la paille dans l'oeil
de notre voisin sans voir la poutre qui
est dans le nôtre parce que plus on se
croit lucide et clairvoyant plus on
devient aveugle à nos propres croyances
et à nos propres préjugés je vais
prendre un exemple beaucoup plus
provocateur mais assez parlant qui est
le rapport que nous avons au règne
animal on sait qu'aujourd'hui un
mouvement se développe de lutte contre
l'exploitation animale qu'on appelle
l'antispécisme imaginez qu'un jour on
finisse par démontrer preuve
scientifique à l'appui
que tous les animaux possèdent une
conscience au même titre que les êtres
humains je précise bien au même titre
que les êtres humains
mais que simplement nous n'avions pas
les outils qui nous ont permis de
détecter l'existence de cette conscience
à ce moment-là on regardera toutes les
personnes qui mangeaient de la viande
comme des cannibales aujourd'hui on est
à peu près tous d'accord pour dire que
le cannibalisme reposait sur une
conception archaïque de la vie humaine
mais si demain on prouve que tous ceux
qui mangent actuellement de la viande
sont des cannibales on aura l'air malin
donc c'est pour ça que je dis que faute
de savoir on est obligé de croire et que
nous ne sommes pas davantage émanciper
de la croyance que ne l'était ceux qui
ont vécu des milliers d'années avant
nous simplement le pôle de la croyance
s'est déplacé sur d'autres questions et
on regarde avec un œil un peu
paternaliste un peu condescendant
ce qui n'avaient pas compris ce que nous
avons compris depuis mais c'est ce même
oeil paternaliste et condescendant que
vont porter sur nous ceux qui vont nous
suivre et je terminerai de répondre à
cette question en faisant un parallèle
entre la religion et la politique parce
qu'on est très fort quand il s'agit de
dénoncer les croyances et les
comportements religieux sans voir que
les schémas de ces comportements sont
exactement les mêmes que chez les
militants politiques un religieux
convaincu un religieux fervent
verra partout la marque de la présence
de Dieu
il vous dira dieu est partout
un militant politique vous dira la
politique est partout
il vous dira tout est politique un
religieux voudra convertir les gens
autour de lui un militant politique
voudra convaincre les gens autour de lui
un religieux pense que si tout le monde
partage ses croyances le monde sera
sauvé un militant pense que si tout le
monde partage ses opinions la société
sera sauvée un religieux va se référer à
un dogme à son texte religieux le
militant va se référer à un dogme sa
doctrine politique donc dans les deux
cas on sacralise les idées on s'interdit
de les remettre en question et on se
demande pas si une idée est vraie ou
fausse on se demande si elle est
conforme ou pas au dogme donc dans les
deux cas il y a besoin de se référer à
un dogme pour savoir ce qu'il faut
penser il ne faut surtout pas essayer de
penser par soi-même il ne faut surtout
pas essayer de sortir du cadre parce que
sortir du cadre c'est dangereux sortir
du cadre c'est prendre le risque d'avoir
des mauvaises pensées donc aujourd'hui
on traite quelqu'un de facho pour
disqualifier ses idées comme autrefois
ont traité quelqu'un de païen pour
disqualifier ses croyances dans les deux
cas il y a l'idée que soit on pense bien
soit on pense mal et que si on pense mal
il n'y a pas à faire l'effort de
produire une réfutation il y a juste à
prendre la personne qui pense mal et à
la mettre dans la case des gens qui
pensent mal pour croire qu'on a réussi à
la disqualifier et dans la religion
comme dans le militantisme politique il
y a besoin de désigner le mal il y a
besoin de désigner l'ennemi donc dans la
religion le mal c'est le diable et chez
les militants politiques le mal c'est
soit le fascisme soit le communisme dans
les deux cas pour la religion comme pour
le militantisme il y a l'incapacité à
admettre que l'on puisse penser
différemment dans les deux cas on a les
prêtres les prêtres se sont ceux qui
vous livrent la bonne version la bonne
interprétation de la ligne à suivre
c'est ce qu'on appelle littéralement les
querelles de chapelle et les querelles
de chapelles sont les plus destructrices
et dans la religion comme dans le
militantisme politique on ni la réalité
quand la réalité contredit notre pensée
donc c'est ce qui fait que le militant
de droite va totalement nier les
inégalités de richesse tandis que le
militant de gauche va totalement nier
l'insécurité donc là dessus je suis sur
la ligne de Simone Veil la philosophe
qui disait que la politique c'était le
contraire de la pensée parce que le
militant politique ne cherche pas la
vérité le militant politique cherche à
convaincre les autres qu'il a raison
question suivante comment reconnaître
une personne intelligente bah souvent
une personne qu'on va décrire comme
intelligente c'est une personne qui a la
qualité de penser comme nous je pense
qu'il y a aussi un biais d'auto
complaisance qui fait qu'on va
considérer comme intelligent ce qui nous
ressemble ou ce qui correspond à ce que
pour moi l'intelligence c'est la
capacité à supporter la contradiction
par rapport à ce que l'on pense c'est à
dire que si on m'oppose une idée avec
laquelle a priori je ne suis pas
d'accord c'est être capable d'envisager
dans quelle mesure cette idée peut être
vrai et ne pas réagir spontanément en se
disant cette personne est stupide ou
cette personne n'a rien compris un
esprit intelligent c'est un esprit
capable de se remettre en cause de telle
sorte qu'il peut progresser et si le
militantisme c'est bel et bien le
contraire de l'intelligence je dirais
que l'intelligence c'est la capacité à
pouvoir remettre en cause que l'on croit
être vrai question suivante comment ne
pas être affecté par les critiques alors
ne pas être affecté par les critiques ça
ne se décrète pas vraiment je dirais que
c'est surtout une question de
tempérament et aussi une question
d'habitude il y a des personnes pour qui
l'image qu'elles vont avoir la
réputation qu'elles vont avoir aux yeux
des autres va être quelque chose
d'absolument déterminant ces personnes
là si elles apprennent qu'on les
critique elles apprennent qu'on
sont faites par des personnes dans
lesquelles vous avez confiance par des
personnes qui ont pu déjà vous témoigner
leur bienveillance et à ce moment là
vous aurez davantage intérêt à prendre
en compte ces critiques mais d'une
manière générale je trouve qu'on a tous
un peu tendance à surdramatiser
certaines choses et notamment à
surgramatiser le regard que les autres
ont sur nous et les critiques qu'ils
peuvent éventuellement faire de nous moi
je pense qu'une personne qui critique en
dit davantage sur elle-même que sur
celui qu'elle critique et qu'on est
souvent très fort pour critiquer chez
l'autre ce qui ne va pas chez nous les
plus grands militants de la pureté pour
reparler des militants sont souvent des
personnes qui ont des petites choses à
se reprocher du point de vue de leur
conscience ce sont souvent des personnes
qui vont chercher à combattre le mal à
l'extérieur d'elle-même pour mieux
éviter de combattre le mal à l'intérieur
d'elle-même le besoin de critiquer a
souvent pour fondement une peur un
besoin de contrôle et je pense qu'on
aurait tout intérêt à s'émanciper de
l'importance je pense qu'on accorde à
certaines critiques question suivante
que redoutes-tu le plus dans la vie ce
que je redoute le plus c'est de ne pas
voir le temps de faire tout ce que j'ai
à faire
quel est le but dans ta vie question 10
bras de la chaîne
ibratv il bras que je ne présente plus
le but dans ma vie brame je dirais que
c'est de créer et de laisser derrière
moi quelque chose que j'estime
utile au groupe et qui me donnera en
contrepartie le sentiment très égoïste
d'avoir fait quelque chose de bien
question suivante comment tu vas en ce
moment et bien écoute je vais très bien
un petit peu fatigué parce que je
travaille sur plusieurs projets en
parallèle dont notamment le fameux
projet dont je vous ai parlé au début de
cette FAQ le projet de la bande dessinée
avec Jules donc la bande dessinée qui va
s'intituler filorama les petites
histoires des grands philosophes et donc
tu me donnes l'occasion de vous rappeler
que si vous avez envie de précommander
la BD il vous suffit de suivre le lien
vers la page Ulule qui se trouve en
commentaire épinglé et dans la
description de cette vidéo
comment te sens-tu maintenant que tu as
arrêté de donner des cours pour te
consacrer au reste et bien écoute je me
sens beaucoup mieux depuis que j'ai
arrêté les cours non pas que je ne
souhaitais plus voir mes élèves mais
tout simplement par ce que quand on a
plusieurs activités en parallèle c'est
très difficile de se concentrer sur une
seule et bah quand je commence à
travailler sur un épisode mais que je
sais qu'il va falloir que je m'arrête
dans une heure pour partir donner cours
qu'ensuite je vais devoir rentrer
j'aurai d'autres choses à faire avant de
pouvoir m'y remettre ça casse ma
concentration ça casse mon rythme et
donc c'était la meilleure chose que je
puisse faire que de me consacrer
simplement à la réalisation de mes
épisodes et à mes projets annexes je
suis très content d'avoir été professeur
particulier pendant des années j'en tire
vraiment une certaine gloire une
certaine fierté mais je pense que le
moment était venu de passer à autre
chose l'existence fonctionne souvent
comme ça par succession de cycles
j'étais à la fin d'un cycle et donc
maintenant je vais pouvoir me consacrer
à plein temps au travail sur mes
épisodes
et tu entourer au quotidien de personnes
qui partagent ta passion pour la philo
alors non j'ai assez peu de personnes
qui partagent ma passion pour la philo
et c'est tant mieux parce qu'il faut
savoir que quand je retrouve mes amis
quand je retrouve mes proches et qu'on
fait l'apéro ensemble je n'ai pas
spécialement envie de parler de
philosophie à ce moment-là parce que la
philosophie c'est ma passion mais c'est
aussi mon métier et je trouve dans mon
métier le moyen d'assouvir cette passion
et comme je fais la différence entre la
passion et l'obsession j'arrive
parfaitement à parler d'autres choses
que de philosophie heureusement
d'ailleurs et donc généralement les
personnes avec qui je passe le plus de
temps pour le loisir on parle de choses
beaucoup plus légères question suivante
bonjour Charles que penses-tu des vidéos
d'Antoine Goya qui sont axés sur la
philosophie et le cinéma en général
alors Antoine Goya je connais sa chaîne
depuis très longtemps je pense même
quasiment depuis la première vidéo qu'il
avait faite en réponse à un live de
Teddy boy RSA sur l'écrivain Céline et
je me rappelle même qu'à cette époque il
y avait chez toi une forme de
ressentiment une forme mais en tout cas
de nervosité maintenant il est beaucoup
plus détendu dans ces vidéos et bah il
se trouve que je partage un point commun
avec Antoine Goya qui est que lui comme
moi nous utilisons Youtube c'est à dire
une plateforme de divertissement pour
essayer de propager de la culture mais
Antoine a bien compris que le premier
usage de YouTube c'était le
divertissement et donc il adopte une
stratégie pédagogique différent de la
mienne c'est à dire que lui il va
utiliser le clash pour attirer des gens
vers ces vidéos de manière à ensuite
pouvoir leur parler de culture japatte
les gens avec du sang d'accord j'apatte
les gens avec du sang et après et ben tu
as bien vu et après j'aurais refilé des
images j'aurais refilé naissance de la
tragédie j'ai mis des gens qui venaient
pour le sang en contact avec des oeuvres
et donc ça je pense que ça vient du fait
que Antoine comme moi et professeur et
quand on est professeur on est
directement confronté à la problématique
de l'attention de la captation de
l'attention de nos élèves et on sait que
pour capter l'attention des élèves il
faut partir de ce qui les intéresse de
ce qui les motive ou de ce qu'il est
touche très généralement ils choisit un
youtubeur plus ou moins connu avec
lequel il est en désaccord il l'injurie
copieusement parce que moi je ne suis
pas une prostituée contrairement à
d'autres avant de nous exposer une autre
manière de penser les choses une autre
manière de comprendre très souvent ce
référant à des auteurs moi je vous
estime monsieur j'estime que
Chateaubriand c'est pour vous également
vous méritez Chateaubriand mais il y a
aussi que Antoine Goya parfois je le
trouve de mauvaise foi je te trouve de
mauvaise foi Antoine et notamment jeté
surpris une fois en flagrant délit de
mauvaise foi j'ai la preuve de ta
mauvaise foi dans une de tes vidéos dans
laquelle tu répondais à Bruno le salé
sur la question de l'art et pour ça tu
as mobilisé un texte de Léon Tolstoï et
il se trouve que malheureusement pour
toi je venais de terminer la lecture de
ce livre au moment où tu as sorti ta
vidéo et j'ai pu déceler un mensonge de
ta part et comme je sais que tu aimes
bien qu'on prouve ce dont on accuse je
vais prouver maintenant devant tout le
monde que tu as menti sur l'entolstoï et
je vais le faire comme tu le fais
toi-même directement à partir des textes
puisque j'ai le livre juste là
Léon Tolstoï qu'est-ce que l'art et donc
dans ta vidéo tu dis que Bruno a tort de
considérer que le but de l'art se
devrait être la beauté que le but de
l'art ce serait la création du beau et
tu t'appuies pour ça sur Tolstoï qui dit
que le but de l'art ce n'est pas de
créer la beauté mais c'est de véhiculer
des émotions mais là il y a un vrai
problème surtout avec ce que tu racontes
avec ton discours ce problème c'est
qu'on s'en bat les couilles de savoir si
une oeuvre d'art est belle et là je vais
parler d'un texte que j'ai lu il y a
très peu de temps parce que justement je
voulais te répondre et puis je suis
tombé dessus totalement par hasard c'est
un test de Tolstoï qui s'appelle
qu'est-ce que l'art donc tu t'appuies
sur Tolstoï pour critiquer ce que dit
Bruno Sallet à propos de l'art
contemporain en disant que l'art
contemporain on s'en fiche de savoir si
c'est beau ou pas la question c'est de
savoir est-ce que ça procure des
émotions et Tolstoï va prendre le prime
à l'envers il va dire bah moi je vais
pas faire une définition de l'art en
fonction des œuvres que j'ai envie qui
appartiennent à l'art parce qu'en fait
tout simplement ça voudrait dire mettre
juste simplement les oeuvres qui te
plaisent des actes que toi tu trouves
belle dans l'art et puis rejeter tout le
reste moi je vais essayer de faire une
définition sans ça donc pour lui là ça
va être plus quelque chose qui va
véhiculer une émotion donc déjà tu as
conception du beau dans l'art c'était
déjà rejeté au 19e siècle mais sauf que
ce que tu ne dis pas en toi c'est que
après avoir défini l'art comme une
activité qui consiste à véhiculer des
émotions
Tolstoï va plus loin la définition
donnée par Tolstoï de l'art on la trouve
en page 58
mais le livre fait
215 pages et donc entre la page 58 et la
page de 115
battle Stoy il dit beaucoup de choses je
vais lire quelques passages du texte de
Tolstoï et je vais intégrer quelques
extraits de ta vidéo pour que tout le
monde puisse se rendre compte de ce que
je suis en train d'expliquer tu dis que
Tolstoï défini l'art par le simple fait
de véhiculer des émotions mais tu ne dis
pas que page 163 Tolstoï exprime que
l'art est bon s'il produit en l'homme
des sentiments et des émotions qui le
conduisent au bonheur pourquoi est-ce
que tu ne le dis pas je cite de même que
procède l'évolution des connaissances ou
sans cesse des connaissances plus
réelles et plus utiles se substitue à
d'autres moins réelles et moins utiles
de même aussi procède l'évolution des
sentiments par le moyen de l'art au
sentiment inférieur moins bon et moins
utile pour le bonheur de l'homme se
substitue sans cesse des sentiments
meilleurs plus utiles à ce bonheur telle
est la destination de l'art et par
conséquent l'arrêt d'autant meilleur
quant à son contenu qu'il rempl mieux
cette destination il est d'autant moins
bon qu'il la remplit moins bien le but
de l'art n'est pas de te faire du bien
et si tu de faire du bien va te tirer
sur la tige et laisse-la en dehors de
tout ça merci pourquoi tu ne dis pas en
toi que pour Tolstoï le fait que le but
de l'art se soit de véhiculer des
émotions c'est dans un but d'unir les
hommes entre eux pourquoi tu ne dis pas
par exemple c'est la propriété
essentielle de l'art de tout art d'unir
les hommes entre eux tout tard a pour
effet que les hommes qui reçoivent le
sentiment transmis par l'artiste se
trouve par là Unis d'abord avec
l'artiste lui-même et en second lieu
avec tous les autres hommes qui
reçoivent la même impression mais l'art
non chrétien en unissant entre quelques
hommes isole ses hommes par la même du
reste de l'humanité de telle façon que
cette union partiel est souvent une
cause d'éloignement à l'égard d'autres
hommes l'art chrétien au contraire est
celui qui unit tous les hommes sans
exception et il peut atteindre ce but de
deux façons ou bien en évoquant chez
tous les hommes la conscience de leurs
parenté avec Dieu et entre eux ou bien
encore en évoquant chez tous les hommes
un même sentiment si simple soit-il
pourvu qu'il ne fut pas contraire au
christianisme et puis s'étendre à tous
les hommes sans exception seul ces deux
ordres de sentiment peuvent former dans
notre temps la matière de la bon quant
au contenu c'est vraiment le niveau zéro
de l'analyse est-ce que je comprends pas
Antoine c'est que quand Bruno le
salelait dit que l'art dans l'espace
public devrait être au service du peuple
tu te moques de lui l'art dans l'espace
et de ce qu'il désire pour embellir son
quotidien et non je suis désolé l'art ne
doit pas être au service du peuple ça
sort d'où cette connerie l'art doit être
au service du peuple ça sort d'où ça
sort de Tolstoï Antoine ce même Tolstoï
que tu cites en référence c'est Tolstoï
qui dit Collard doit s'adresser au
peuple et je vais te le prouver je cite
du jour où l'art des classes supérieures
c'est séparé avec l'art du peuple cette
conviction est née que l'art pouvait
être l'art et rester cependant hors de
la portée des masses et du jour où ce
principe a été admis on pouvait prévoir
que le moment viendrait ou l'art ne
serait plus accessible qu'à un petit
nombre d'élus et qu'il finirait même par
ne plus l'être qu'à deux ou trois
personnes voire à une seule l'artiste
qui le produirait c'est vraiment le
niveau zéro de l'analyse et alors là
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau parce
qu'après être moqué de Bruno parce qu'il
disait que l'art devait s'adresser au
peuple tu dis toi-même que Tolstoï dit
la même chose dans son livre je vais te
raconter un truc dans le bouquin de
Tolstoï donc je t'ai dit après il s'en
prend à la modernité vous savez à
monnaie à Verlaine à Baudelaire etc et
il dit là en fait il y a deux façons
qu'on se voit là il y a l'art actuel à
son époque du coup qui considère comme
un art illitiste donc pour lui monnaie
etc ça existe il me parle plus au peuple
il dit l'art doit parler au peuple et
pour lui le seul art qui parle au peuple
c'est l'art chrétien donc voilà donc on
est là dessus donc là je sais pas si tu
te rends compte Antoine mais en fait ce
que tu dis c'est que Bruno le salait est
d'accord avec
tolstoïstoï sur lequel tu t'appuies pour
contredire Bruno donc va falloir nous
expliquer quelque chose est-ce que tu
sous-entends que Tolstoï a raison
seulement quand tu es d'accord avec lui
est-ce que tu si Tolstoï seulement quand
ce qu'il dit va dans ton sens mais c'est
pour ça tu vois que je dis que tu es une
mauvaise foi c'est à dire que toi qui
aime bien dénoncer les sophisme tu
utilises ce que les esthéticiens
appellent le Cherry picking c'est à dire
le prélèvement prélèvement sélectif et
donc tu vas chercher chez Tolstoï
quelque chose qui va te permettre de
ridiculiser Bruno le salé mais sauf que
tu n'utilises Tolstoï que pour ce qui
t'arrange autrement dit tu n'utilises
pas ce que dit olstoï et qui va
exactement dans le sens de ce que dit
Bruno le salé et ça je trouve que c'est
pas très honnête parce que ça donne
l'impression pour les personnes qui
n'ont pas lu Tolstoï et je pense que sur
les conscient ça donne l'impression que
tu as répondu de manière cinglante et
définitive un youtubeur qui ne
maîtrisait pas son sujet et peut-être
effectivement que Bruno Sallet ne
maîtrise pas le sujet de l'histoire de
l'art ou de l'art contemporain mais
prélevez quelques lignes sur un livre de
200 pages pour donner l'impression que
tu as raison c'est ça qui me fait dire
que tu es de mauvaise foi et je sais que
pour beaucoup de personnes tu passes
pour un érudit pour quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup lu et que donc si tu t'attaques
à un sujet a priori c'est toi qui va
gagner la confrontation
mais si les personnes prennent la peine
de lire qu'est-ce que l'art de Tolstoï
de A à Z et bien ils vont pouvoir se
rendre compte que dans ta vidéo tu
triches bon on est dans la rhétorique
voilà bon un petit sophisme de temps en
temps pour convaincre son audience ça
passe beaucoup mieux prélever des
références littéraires sur lesquels on
va bâtir une argumentation et mettre
complètement de côté le reste de ce que
dit l'auteur qui ne va pas dans le sens
de ton argumentation mais je trouve que
c'est pas très honnête alors je peux
comprendre que le fait de définir l'art
par la beauté ou par la technique que ce
soit quelque chose qui t'exaspère mais
est-ce que ça justifie que tu te réfère
à des auteurs comme à des autorités
philosophiques
et que tu leur fasses dire la moitié de
ce qu'ils disent vraiment uniquement
pour servir ton propos et que donc si tu
considères Tolstoï comme une référence
sur la question de l'art et de la
définition de l'art pourquoi est-ce que
tu ne prends pas sa définition complète
de la donc là je vais vous lire le début
du chapitre 8 du livre de Tolstoï dans
lequel Tolstoï déplore le fait que l'art
est perdu sa dimension morale et
religieuse je cite
le manque de foi des classes supérieures
a produit ce résultat qu'au lieu d'un
artendant à transmettre les plus hauts
sentiments de l'humanité c'est-à-dire
ceux qui découlent d'une conception
religieuse de la vie nous avons eu un
art ne tendant qu'à procurer la plus
grande somme de plaisir à une certaine
classe de la société et de tout
l'immense domaine de l'art seul cette
partie a été cultivée qui procure du
plaisir à cette classe privilégiée et
pour ne rien dire des effets moraux qu'a
eu sur la société européenne une telle
perversion de la notion de l'art cette
perversion a encore affaibli l'art
lui-même et là pour ainsi dire détruit
elle a eu pour premiers résultats que
l'art en faisant du plaisir son seul
objet c'est privé de la source de sujets
infiniment variés et profonde que
pouvait être pour lui les conceptions
religieuses de la vie et son second
résultat a été que ne s'adressant qu'à
un petit cercle l'art a perdu la beauté
de sa forme et devenue affectée et
obscur
et son troisième et principal résultat a
été Collard a cessé d'être spontané ou
même sincère pour devenir absolument
apprêté et artificielle donc là Tolstoï
contredit ta vision de l'art à deux
niveaux premièrement parce que pour lui
la véritable c'est la religieux plus
précisément la chrétien or on sait ce
que tu penses de la religion c'est sa
région des débiles ok enfin c'est une
religion tu as compris quoi et
deuxièmement quand tu dis qu'on s'en
fout de savoir si une oeuvre d'art est
belle on s'en bat les couilles de savoir
si une oeuvre d'art est belle j'en
déduis donc que quand Tolstoï déplore le
fait que l'art est perdu la beauté de sa
forme ça veut dire que tu te réfère à un
auteur qui dit n'importe quoi alors là
le passage que je vais lire est
intéressant parce qu'il répond
directement à ce que tu as répondu à
Victor ferry lorsqu'il disait que le
film titane était un film absolument nul
et que ce n'était pas ça le but de l'art
ce n'était pas de montrer des femmes en
train de copuler avec des voitures ce
film est juste bon à faire frétiller les
intellos à donner un vernis culturel à
ceux qui n'osent pas assumer pleinement
leur swap de gore et de cochons regardez
quand je regarde par la fenêtre hop non
on ne voit pas de femme qui copulent
avec des voitures donc là qu'est-ce que
tu as répondu à Victor ferry tu lui as
répondu qu'il avait je cite une
rhétorique de curé là clairement on a
une rhétorique de curé d'accord il y a
aucun argument c'est une rhétorique de
curé oh là là je fais de la psychologie
de comptoir regarde c'est du vernis
intellectuel pas dessus le cochon le
cochon c'est pas bien le cochon on
dirait une phrase tu aurais pu nous
sortir l'imam de Molenbeek entre deux
Jupiler et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que Tolstoï dans son livre dénonce
exactement la même chose que Victor
ferry à savoir la sexualisation de l'art
mais sa curieusement tu n'en parles pas
regardons ce qui écrit Tolstoï ces pages
85 plus tard l'élément du désir sexuel a
commencé à pénétrer de plus en plus dans
l'art il est devenu désormais très peu
d'exceptions près un élément essentiel
dans tous les produits artistiques des
classes riches et en particulier dans
les romans de Bocas à marcel Prévost
tous les romans comptent et poèmes
expriment le sentiment de l'amour sexuel
sous ses formes diverses l'adultère et
le thème favori pour ne pas dire
l'unique thème de tous les romans une
représentation théâtrale a pour
condition indispensable que sous un
prétexte quelconque des femmes
apparaissent sur la scène avec le buste
et les membres nus les opéras et les
chansons tout est consacré à
l'idéalisation de la luxure la grande
majorité des tableaux des peintres
français représentent le nu féminin dans
la nouvelle littérature française à
peine s'il y a une page ou
n'apparaissent le mot nu là clairement
on a une rhétorique de curé d'accord il
y a aucun argument pour lui c'est
vraiment là le sujet qui lui pose
problème c'est rien que le fait qu'on
lui dise il y a une femme qui va se
prendre un truc sur les seins oh bah
pour lui c'est pas beau de base c'est
pas beau et peu importe comment est-ce
que c'est traité d'accord il y a aucune
analyse esthétique peu importe comment
c'est traité peu importe le réalisateur
de film ce sera moche c'est vraiment le
niveau zéro de et on pourrait continuer
comme ça pendant longtemps je vais lire
un autre passage dans lequel Tolstoï
Antoine te donne tort sur ce que tu dis
à propos du jugement de la majorité
qu'on se disait je pense que 99% des
gens sont d'accord avec moi c'est de la
branlette intellectuelle et c'est de la
merde bon déjà il faudrait prouver que
99 % des personnes sont d'accord avec
toi et puis surtout il faudrait prouver
que ça veut dire quelque chose sous 99%
des personnes sont d'accord avec toi ça
ça juste un appel à la majorité tu dis
qu'on ne peut pas s'appuyer sur le
critère de la majorité pour décider si
une oeuvre d'art est réussie ou pas je
pense il ne faut pas donner au peuple ce
qu'il veut parce que le peuple en fait
de toute façon n'a aucune idée de ce
qu'il veut et surtout il veut de la
merde voilà ça me semble assez évident
et surtout l'artiste est censé être
maître à bord c'est lui qui décide
quelle vision il a c'est lui le génie et
c'est à nous de lui courir après et bien
il se trouve que Tolstoï n'est pas
d'accord avec toi et je vais te le
démontrer dire qu'une œuvre d'art est
bonne et cependant incompréhensible à la
majorité des hommes c'est comme si l'on
disait d'un certain aliment qui est bon
mais que la plupart des hommes doivent
se garder dans manger la majorité des
hommes peut ne pas aimer le fromage
pourri ou le gibier faisant des mais
estimé par des hommes dont le goût est
perverti mais le pain et les fruits ne
sont bons que quand ils plaisent à la
majorité des hommes et le cas et le même
pour large l'art perverti peut ne pas
plaire à la majorité des hommes mais le
bon art doit forcément plaire à tout le
monde et puis surtout il faudrait
prouver que ça veut dire quelque chose
sous 99% des personnes sont d'accord
avec toi ça ça juste un appel à la
majorité tu te moques de Bruno en disant
que si le critère de la majorité était
un critère pertinent et bien à ce
moment-là il faudrait considérer que
Avengers c'est une œuvre d'art on
propose au peuple voilà on me dit Oh
qu'est-ce que tu vas aller voir au
cinéma qu'est-ce qui va voir il va avoir
à manger avant j'ai en gamme donc de
deux choses l'une Antoine soit tu te
fies à ta propre définition de l'art ou
plutôt à celle que tu as prise chez
Tolstoï à savoir que l'art a pour
fonction de
si donc l'art de notre temps est
incompréhensible pour la masse ce n'est
point parce qu'il est trop bon comme les
artistes se plaisent aujourd'hui à le
dire si cet art est incompréhensible à
la masse c'est simplement parce qu'il
est de mauvaises arts ou même que cet
art n'est pas de l'art du tout l'objet
des œuvres d'art étant d'exprimer des
émotions comment peut-on parler de ne
pas les comprendre un homme du peuple
lit un livre voit une peinture entend
une pièce ou une symphonie et une
éprouve aucune émotion on lui dit que
c'est parce qu'il ne peut pas comprendre
on lui promet de lui montrer quelque
chose il entre et ne voit rien et on lui
dit que c'est parce que sa vue n'est pas
préparée pour un spectacle de ce genre
mais cet homme sait qu'il voit très bien
et s'il ne voit pas ce qu'on lui a
promis de lui montrer il en conclut
simplement à juste titre que ceux qui
ont entrepris de lui faire voir le
spectacle non pas rempli leur engagement
et de dire que si mon art ne touche pas
à un certain homme la faute en est à ce
que cet homme est trop stupide outre que
c'est un comble de vanité c'est encore
un renversement des rôles comme si un
malade engageait un homme bien portant à
se mettre au lit mais en fait moi ce que
je vois c'est que vous avez des
bienfaits de capacités réflexives vous
avez juste pas envie de vous poser la
question vous avez juste la flemme c'est
vraiment le niveau zéro de l'analyse
donc moi ce que je pense c'est que s'il
n'y avait pas marqué Léon Tolstoï sur la
couverture de ce livre et que tu étais
tombé sur l'extrait que je viens de lire
à l'instant tu aurais pu en faire une
vidéo pour dire à quel point c'était
stupide tu aurais pu faire une vidéo
pour dire à quel point c'est stupide de
se référer à l'avis de la majorité en
matière d'art en matière de jugement
esthétique parce que tu le dis toi-même
tu n'es pas démocrate justement parce
que tu considères que la majorité la
plupart du temps pense n'importe quoi je
ne suis pas démocrate pour éviter ça
justement la démocratie ça te pousse à
te faire croire que ton opinion est
légitime sur absolument tous les sujets
tu n'y connais rien sur un sujet
normalement tu n'as pas d'opinion sur ce
sujet là donc là je viens de démontrer
que tu t'appuies sur des auteurs que tu
cites de de manière tronquée simplement
pour donner l'apparence d'avoir raison
par rapport à quelqu'un qui n'a pas tes
référence littéraires ou philosophiques
mais dont le contenu du propos est
finalement plus proche de la pensée des
auteurs que tu utilises que tu ne les
toi-même donc pourquoi tu ouvres ta
gueule pourquoi tu ouvres ta gueule
voilà j'ai terminé ma démonstration en
toile que parfois tu utilises les
références quand elles t'arrange et j'ai
une petite pensée pour mon bouquin de
Tolstoï j'avais juste envie de remettre
certaines choses en place quant à la
manière dont certains spectateurs
absolutisent la parole de leur gourou et
que derrière un personnage sur youtube
il y a un être humain et que parfois
l'être humain est de mauvaise foi quand
il a envie de régler des comptes est-ce
que tu vas continuer à faire des vidéos
sur des sujets que tu ne maîtrises pas
ou est-ce que tu vas te remettre en
question te rendre compte que tu n'as
pas à parler sur ces sujets là à moins
de t'être renseigné profondément
question suivante
le déterminisme et le libre arbitre
sont-ils vraiment incompatibles alors là
on en revient à ce fameux sujet le
fameux combat entre le déterminisme et
le libre arbitre et bien je ne pense pas
que les deux soient incompatibles je
pense plutôt que on ne comprend pas
exactement de quoi on parle quand on
parle de déterminisme et de libre
arbitre parce que on voudrait absolument
utiliser ces deux notions on voudrait
croire que tout est absolument déterminé
au même titre ou alors on voudrait
croire que le libre arbitre supposerait
l'absence totale d'influence sur notre
pensée et je pense que dans les deux cas
on se trompe je pense qu'il y a un
déterminisme qui ne s'applique pas
exactement de la même manière sur les
corps purement physique et sur les corps
spirituels c'est-à-dire sur les
individus dotés d'une conscience à
partir du moment où nous sommes des
êtres matériels nous sommes des êtres
contraints nous sommes contraints par la
gravité nous sommes contraints par la
causalité nous sommes contraints par nos
origines par notre environnement donc on
ne peut pas s'abstraire on peut pas
s'émanciper de toutes ces déterminations
de toutes ces contraintes de toutes ces
influences en revanche on peut en avoir
conscience et à partir du moment où on
en a conscience on peut en être un peu
moins l'esclave mais dire que tout est
déterminé au même titre c'est-à-dire
sans faire de hiérarchie dans ce
déterminisme je pense que c'est non
seulement abusif mais c'est aussi très
réducteur parce que ce n'est pas la même
chose que de dire que nos choix sont
déterminés par notre vécu par notre
sensibilité par notre tempérament ce
n'est pas la même chose que de dire que
ce livre est déterminé à tomber par
terre si je le lance parce que dans le
cas de l'être humain il y a ce qu'on
appelle la possibilité la possibilité
d'échapper aux prédictions aux
prévisions c'est à dire la possibilité
d'être l'exception au déterminisme quand
on dit que la plupart des personnes qui
occupent des positions de pouvoir ou des
positions sociales privilégiées sont
issus de famille dans lesquels on
occupait déjà des positions de pouvoir
et des positions sociales privilégiées
c'est vrai ça s'appelle la reproduction
sociale et c'est pas un secret mais on
est bien d'accord que ce déterminisme
social là il admet des exceptions donc
si l'admet des exceptions ça veut dire
que tout n'est pas totalement
entièrement déterminé comme on voudrait
le croire parce qu'il y a un degré de
complexité dans le déterminisme humain
qui fait qu'on ne peut pas mettre tous
les déterministes exactement sur le même
plan moi ce que je prône dans la
réflexion sur le déterminisme c'est la
question du degré c'est la question du
curseur je pense qu'on est plus ou moins
déterminé je pense que l'on est plus ou
moins soumis à la chaîne du déterminisme
et c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs qu'il
existe ce qu'on appelle l'emprise
mentale
existe la manipulation qu'il existe
l'aliénation et ces notions ne peuvent
avoir de sens que si on part du principe
que le libre arbitre existe puisque
l'emprise la manipulation mentale le
conditionnement ce sont des phénomènes
qui alternent notre libre arbitre donc
dire que le libre arbitre n'existe pas
c'est un peu court si le libre arbitre
n'existe pas bien à ce moment-là
l'altération du libre arbitre n'existe
pas donc l'emprise la manipulation
mentale l'aliénation n'existe pas non
plus donc moi tout ce que je prône c'est
un peu plus de modération un peu moins
de radicalité dans l'exposé de notre
opinion sur le déterminisme question
suivante
faudrait-il cesser d'imaginer pour ne
plus avoir peur bien très souvent oui
très souvent la peur vient de ce qu'on
imagine davantage que de ce qu'on vit la
peur normalement est un signal qui a une
fonction fonction physiologique qui est
de nous alerter d'un danger et donc
parfois l'anticipation du danger
l'anticipation excessive du danger fait
qu'on va avoir peur dans une situation
où la peur est inutile donc il me semble
qu'on a très souvent tendance à imaginer
le pire à dramatiser l'avenir et que si
on se contentait de réagir aux
événements au moment où on est en train
de les vivre on aurait beaucoup moins
peur et on serait beaucoup plus heureux
question suivante quelle réponse
cherchez-vous à avoir via la philosophie
je dirais que via la philosophie
je cherche à savoir
si on peut être dans le vrai est-ce que
tu as des questions philosophiques
restées toujours sans réponse
aujourd'hui oui savoir si on peut
accéder au vrai
selon toi y a-t-il un lien entre vertuer
intelligence je dirais que
l'intelligence
c'est ce qui permet de tordre la vertu
avez-vous déjà eu l'occasion de sortir
de la caverne de remettre en cause une
croyance idée reçue alors sortir de la
caverne j'irai pas jusque là je n'ai pas
encore contemplé le ciel des idées en
revanche remettre en cause des croyances
et des préjugés oui ça m'arrive
régulièrement et d'ailleurs je considère
même que ça c'est une bonne question à
poser à quelqu'un qui pratique
l'esprit critique de lui poser la
question quelle est la dernière fois que
tu t'es rendu compte que tu avais une
fausse croyance que tu croyais dans une
idée reçue j'en ai parlé dans une
publication sur Instagram je vous invite
à vous abonner à mon compte Instagram
lorsque j'ai découvert le tir le tir
sportif et je pensais comme beaucoup de
gens que le tir était une activité
réservée à des gens qui avaient
peut-être un petit problème
psychologique à des gens fascinés par la
mort à des gens
qui rêvait de commettre des massacres de
masse et quand je suis arrivé au stand
je me suis rendu compte que mes préjugés
étaient vraiment ridicule et que j'avais
à faire à des personnes qui non
seulement avaient l'air tout à fait
saine d'esprit mais qui respectait aussi
des règles de sécurité qui expliquent
d'ailleurs que le tierce sportif est
l'une des disciplines dans lesquelles on
compte le moins de morts il y a beaucoup
plus de personnes qui meurent en faisant
du ski en faisant de la plongée
sous-marine ou même en faisant du tir à
l'arc que de personnes qui meurent dans
un accident de tir sportif justement
parce que quand on tient une arme
chargée dans les mains et bien on fait
attention on fait attention déjà de ne
pas blesser un proche on fait attention
de ne pas se blesser soi-même et c'est
ce qui explique que ça fait partie des
activités sportives les plus
inoffensives
au moment de partir qu'est-ce qui aura
encore du sens au moment de partir ce
qui aura encore du sens ce sera tout ce
qu'on aura laissé
et tout ce qu'on aura contribué à faire
à devenir
on peut considérer l'existence comme une
quête du bonheur
et il n'est jamais trop tard pour
accéder au bonheur
mais on peut aussi considérer que
l'humanité
se renouvelle de génération en
génération
qu'elle suit son chemin
et que nous sommes une partie de ce
chemin
on peut considérer qu'on ne vit pas que
pour soi en tant qu'individu
et que de la même façon que
nous provenons de millions d'années
d'histoire
et bien nous avons aussi notre pierre à
poser à l'édifice
sur le chemin de l'humanité à titre
individuel on peut pas faire grand-chose
pour l'humanité
mais le peu qu'on peut faire
on doit le faire
quand on est sur terre
on a une responsabilité
la responsabilité
d'accomplir ce qu'on peut accomplir
du type pour le groupe
et dit-il pour la postérité
et il y a mille et une façons
d'accomplir des choses utiles pour le
groupe
ça peut être en produisant des œuvres
ça peut être en donnant de l'amour
en insufflant
de l'espoir de la motivation
tu as pas besoin
d'être un personnage socialement
important
pour être utile au groupe
pour faire du bien à l'humanité
je pense que plus on cherche à faire
beaucoup pour l'humanité
et plus on prend le risque que de ne pas
faire grand-chose
et qu'au contraire plus on se concentre
sur le petit morceau d'amélioration
qu'on peut construire
et plus on a des chances de réussir à le
construire
Ibrah me posait la question de savoir
quel était mon but dans la vie
mon but dans la vie
c'est de proposer
des éléments de réflexion
chacun peut venir se servir
et j'ai l'espoir
que c'est utile
que c'est utile pour le groupe
et que c'est les éléments de réflexion
vont se transmettre
vont circuler dans le monde
à chaque fois qu'on entre en interaction
avec quelqu'un directement ou
indirectement
produit une petite influence sur le
monde
bien je pense que
si on était conscient de l'influence
qu'on produit sur le monde à chaque fois
qu'on agit à chaque fois qu'on parle et
même à chaque fois qu'on pense ou qu'on
ressent
on ferait déjà quelque chose
d'extrêmement utile
en œuvre aurait à rendre le monde
meilleur
et donc peut-être qu'au moment de partir
on se fera le petit bilan comptable
de nos gestes de nos actions de nos
paroles
qui ont contribué à améliorer le monde
et qu'à l'issue de ce bilan
on se dira
j'ai bien vécu
j'ai bien fait de vivre
[Musique]